does anybody think DeSantis can handle a
debate with Donald Trump
I don't know I don't imagine he could
personally I think I mean I think he
would do okay but but to answer your
question I mean no I don't I don't
really think anybody can not even the
moderators
I mean he is he's he's tough to take her
down yeah we made this point when we
were watching the primaries back in uh
it was like 2020 with the Democrats
Andrew Yang's Mike got turned off and
you see him just kind of like mouthing
but not doing anything and they're like
oh whoops and I was like if that was
Donald Trump he would lean over to the
other person like excuse me excuse me my
microphone is off you gotta turn it on
it's I I need to say it I think if
you're gonna beat it if you're gonna
beat Trump in a debate you need to
ignore him while he's bloviating and
while he's trying to insult you just be
like this and then keep talking about
what's important and just let him be
like like flames in the background from
the friction you know like it's but if
you try to him and start getting get
playing with his game with him you lose
because he's the best at it